I like how you put you throw people
under the bus wait Emile was James
who's James are you gonna tell me thanks
y'all this [ __ ] I got a bleep out
because of you
let's talk about more gossip hey guys so
we have a special guest today it's
giovanna Antoinette herself because we
couldn't get Megan but - so I just heard
that go for broke lunch and you had
nothing to do with that's funny
1% owner of Marbella hey more than you
owe the line I use against you that's
why I say you have 1% you always say it
Martinez 100 percent what's funny what's
so funny that's funny watching you crash
no let's look at that boy you know it
might crash you crash - right that's
funny
cuz you'll die that's a lady that I'm
leaving you with me that's funny because
I must move the car so the truck rush
into your face that's funny I'm gonna
just pull you in front of me and I'm
gonna survive that's funny you act like
you lift weights can we what do you know
where you going - funny Danielle told
you I'm like that thank you
nobody hugging somebody honking at me
yep you honking I made it it's okay he's
Asian I swear to god honking it's okay
apologies yeah you won't look at me with
this hand a [ __ ] over here honking at
me a [ __ ] like you a CD you plug and put
into the GPS [ __ ] for someone wearing a
shirt that was like he pulled it out of
the dirty laundry today you have a lot
of horrible condition it adds character
you brush your deep today I always brush
my teeth
I brush my teeth for no [ __ ] reason
till it bleeds I'm going every time I'm
with you you bleed I always believe
throw my vagina specifically I went over
the next joke of the lot to say yeah
yeah you can't insult me my self-esteem
is low enough as it is
I've been insulting myself since day one
you know what's hard what I realized on
Instagram or even on Megan's episode
yeah you know everybody has insecurities
yeah but they're like Oh what do you
have to be a secure for you're a pretty
girl you have nothing to complain about
do you get that [ __ ] you know I do it no
I think no I'd only get that [ __ ] cuz I
don't
I don't think I complain I think I do a
really good job of making myself look
really [ __ ] bad that people hate me
oh really I think the two people that
get the most hate on JK is you and me
Jamie Oh mad hey dude Bar and joke and
say like [ __ ] your mom she's a piece of
[ __ ] people are like yeah yeah you know
what sometimes she is pretty bad like I
do agree but then if you and I say your
mom's just not that cool you know why
it's because you hate us because when
you do very well on JK it's just a girl
knows you get alternate opinion now we
have to go we have to go we don't have a
choice you win the whole time Asian
people don't know how to drive thinking
game it's like that episode of Family
Guy the lady like those are constant
traffic how much signal I need to cut
across eight Lane none I turn now good
luck everybody else
make left turn now look everybody else
we made eye contact Hilda you know what
I see you're Asian you're not gonna give
a [ __ ] about Robles that's not just you
in went no because you always are the
one on Jake where's ty my turn you
always give a the of was a call you
always play devil's advocate which is a
good thing people don't understand what
devil's advocate means so they think
that I'm actually yeah I come off like a
dick
well that's the great thing about JK
news like you have to have like
juxtaposing opinions and I think that
everybody they don't realize it it's
just that they kind of want people to
always agree they're like well this is
what they should say but listen I am
everybody said that then we wouldn't
develop conversation yeah absolutely we
wouldn't even involve exactly you need
to have differing opinions and thoughts
because if you don't you kind of get
like interest in your own views and
that's why sometimes we say out loud
this [ __ ] because we have to think about
the other side we do and I mean it's
really cool because it forces us at
least to like you know remove ourselves
from situation and then really try to
like understand all sides of it but what
we fail in doing is walking people
through the step-by-step of how we
arrived at when we're at because for
example if we hear like a crazy
outlandish story right then we're like
oh she's [ __ ] dumb when we really met
was like oh actually she grew up in a
really poor environment causing her to
go to a really poor I don't know school
system she had really [ __ ] up friends
at born positive so we don't walk people
through that thought process it's like
the thought process happens in our head
and we just come out with what we feel
and then I feel like that's what offends
a lot of people too oh I mean
but I don't know but see you're very
good at I see I just call people dumb
and I just feel like I've come
but you're good you're so good I wish I
could talk like you cuz you don't offend
people this thing way I do I don't know
I think it's just that your that's what
I'm saying I think it's like that the
pretty girl syndrome so if people feel
like you are somebody who doesn't have a
right to complain based on looks like
they they say if this person is an
attractive woman you have nothing to
complain about because God made you
pretty for me on the other hand I don't
look a car vent so this give it to me
that like you know what role you suffer
didn't know what God kind of gave you a
[ __ ] up hand so we'll just let it go
okay no I think I think just girls in
general just get a lot of flack you know
what I mean because like if a guy super
if he needed then he's strong he's a man
that's what men do but then if a girl's
super opinionated and she's kind of
going against the grain then she's a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
Oh what why did I get myself into
minutes that's true like I should have
just been a man that's true sometimes
when a girl is very strong I think a guy
feels very like emasculated yeah like oh
that's not how a girl should speak yeah
look if she has her own opinions and
she's not and not to say like I'm
because there's also tactful ways of
saying things I mean sometimes you know
emotions do charge you know how you know
I don't think that you're very um I
don't make me think that you're very
like straightforward in the way that you
speak to you actually you're very good
at like composing yourself it's just
that yeah
comparatively that is only because your
husband is animal and so what can you uh
can you be a little specific because
this animal in all regard because it's
in the sense of like how bark speaks
it's very straightforward is very right
yeah so you take that down a notch but
even you're down a notch is a stream for
other people because it compares the
department is very composed yeah you
know what I mean yeah yeah yeah
I agree hundred percent because Bart's
that [ __ ] to me sometimes I get thrown
off like I never had a man just openly
coming to my office just call me a [ __ ]
in his walk out and that's how he starts
this morning
do you like a cup of coffee we had
Anthony Lee over and like Anthony's
explaining how like it's so cool like
having the social media exposure because
then you gain fans and he's kind of been
noticing more of a growth in his
popularity right he was saying like this
kid saw him on the street and like got
out of his car like I just stops at a
red light or something I was like hey
your so and so from kitchens and the
part just cuts him off but you guys had
even window mix artists why you didn't
even win though and like that like
completely broke the man like I've never
seen him get red and he was just like
he's started getting all defensive and
just started support
that's what York nothing likes to break
down the people maybe he likes because
that's all just waste because even
wasn't the other day I was in the office
and I was like writing a script he goes
because you busy [ __ ] around
he smiles he walks the honey was gonna
tend to say something yeah yeah just
comes in to say some [ __ ] and then walks
out well honestly I don't understand
your work style because every time I
walk by your office your TV is on so
your TV's like mounted on the wall right
next to your monitor you're not even
looking at your monitor that the TV's
tilted facing you your watch this is
what is Lee guy all right can't work
without some type of white noise but it
has to be a white noise I'm familiar
with so a family guy is so you'll always
see me run through two things it's
family guy in office why I've seen all
the episodes
I don't need oh good hey I think these
it's like white noise is very familiar
and I don't need to pay attention to it
so when it gets to quiet my ATD gets
really hardcore and I start bouncing to
different things okay
so I guess one thing to distract me to
keep me on point to something else it's
a very odd system so what about the
times when I walk by and you're on your
couch and the phone right here okay
first of all when you want when you go
hold up
walk in it when you walk in and I'm on
my couch I come in after a long-ass
shoot it's not because I was there the
whole day so you shoot every day every
day every day yeah try to talk [ __ ]
exactly
producing I cannot attack all this BAM
damn well we're we're filming right now
you kind of live how else do you think I
do carpel comedy and how else do you
think I do the Sun they've lost and then
on top of that living out loud should
you want to put your face on bodies I
know what you do that's just really it's
not even David specimen specimen who
this fence ready yeah your specimen
remember what do you say about us
I say great things about you I don't
ever stop me
I don't ever so on camera I specifically
I hate me I know I always say nice
things about you
Wow give me three let's go okay thanks
fine one you're tall you're dead guys
and you got legs
did you tell people yeah Gio my friend
she's so tall with eyes that are big
big-ass legs I'm not sure what you are
told them